and who was that crazy guy who lived
there he was kind of like I mean
honestly yes what was his last name
Porter Chris Porter mr. Chris Porter
reminds me of one of those people who
run those those lyin petting zoos like
in that recent documentary just came out
on Netflix it's a call tiger tiger King
Tiger King he reminds me just like one
of those people like where he just has
that giant swimming pool with all those
dolphins in there and he goes in there
and swims with them and that literally
blew my mind people like you know
there's a bunch of them there you know
there's all these guy on Instagram the
real Tarzan so it showed me as account
the other day and the guy's a clown it's
like it's never about the dolphins or
the animals it's about BAM the animal is
the backdrop and it's always about
getting the picture the Instagram
picture as close as you can with the
chimpanzee with a lion with whatever it
is it's like any true sanctuary does not
let you take selfies with the animal
well you don't like our place where we
have the Dolphins the general public is
not allowed in there there's no one
coming you can't take selfies no one's
coming and swimming with the dolphins
the Dolphins are retired like they're
just there to be wild animals and that's
what wild animals do mm-hmm
I never us you know there's a huge
fascination with the Irwin family and
that you know for me he was one of the
worst things that ever happened to out
animals Steve Irwin you know he's just
trying to promote animals in captivity
and you know before him when I grew up
all the documentaries you know when you
saw a great documentary about lions it
was usually by a husband-and-wife team
that lived in Africa for four years with
the Lions and had the absolute longest
lens you could ever have and got you
right in there with lions being lions
Steve Irwin was all about how close can
I get to the animal and it it was all
about a wide-angle lens not a zoom lens
like how freakin you know how I'll close
on top can I jump out of the truck and
land right on the animal and it changed
the came a spinoff of shows all about
that and it just changed the
relationship and it was it used to be
all about being as far away and letting
the animal be an animal
seeing the behaviors that as soon as you
introduce a person the animals not doing
wild animal behaviors anymore he's doing
something else and so it changed our
whole relationship with animals not for
the better I think
yeah there's sort of this weird primal
desire that humans have to be next to
them or to hold them or to like harness
the power of this wild animal
sanctuaries and it's the person who runs
the sanctuary it's like they're in every
picture it's like right not what I want
to see I want to see the animals just
being animals not you like not about you
yeah it's so it's so weird so the guy
Chris Porter where where does he live
he's Canadian he's Canada he's from
Canada but doesn't he live in like
Indonesia somewhere it was all shut down
he was he was at when I was there he was
out of money like really I was having a
little bit 20 bucks every day just so
he'd buy some food for him and the guy
is like he had no money he had bought
his ticket to be on that episode to get
there and showed up with like zero
dollars like because that was
fascinating man now that was that thing
the way that you guys had to travel to
get there to interview the people that
were living there that lived off these
dolphins I go there all the time
I usually go there twice a year Solomon
Islands that's next to Papua New Guinea
why do you go there twice a year what do
you do when you go there well a couple
things the reason he goat went there is
because Solomon Islands is probably one
of the only places in the world where
they traditionally hunt dolphins
they've been doing it maybe because it's
an orally oral history there but it
could go back 500 years 600 years that
they've been hunting dolphins and in
Solomon's they've kind of mixed like
dolphin hunting in like Christianity and
like Judaism into almost one thing we're
like you know some people equate with
their sign the dolphins that it's the
blood of Christ and then they're in the
Solomons
it's very tribal and so they
do a dowry when they get married and
this the villages that do that Albin I
think dolphin teeth is a very important
part of the dowry when you get married
every wedding the bride and her whole
family are dressed in head-to-toe
wearing dolphin you know headbands and
big ornate necklaces and they string
dolphin teeth together to form like
strings of like almost like money and so
it's very symbolic for them and so with
the dolphin dealers and dolphin hunters
people that sell dolphins aquariums
realized countries that will allow
people to slaughter dolphins will
probably allow us to catch few of them
and export them so people like Chris
Porter realized oh they're slaughtering
dolphins in the Solomons I bet we could
probably export if they're catching them
already we could just pay him a little
extra to catch them for us and we could
export him out of the country to
aquariums and so that's what he did and
so he created a mess where tribes there
were going and just catching dolphins
and you know Chris Porter wouldn't be
around to be in Canada and they just
catch the dolphins and have 30 dolphin's
ten together and they try to keep him
alive until Chris Porter showed up they
didn't know if he was coming in a week
or a month and these are villages that
are barely there catching one fish to
feed themselves for that day you're
living in huts and now they're having to
feed 30 dolphins for some guy that might
give them money and so it just created
disaster scenarios where you know
dolphins were being caught and dying and
these pens and the villages were getting
upset and warring with each other
recover money some white guy and like so
I've been continuing I mean if you see
blood dolphins there's a tribe called
family there in the specific tribe that
really hunt dolphins to this day and
I've been slowly working with them to
see if they will move away from dolphin
hunting and so I built them like schools
and I've been providing the kids
education and different kinds of grants
to the villages as the numbers of
dolphins decrease that are killed and
now do you go there with like a team of
people or no I go by myself or I go
sometimes with um there's an
anthropologist that I work with she's
lives in Miami and she did her doctoral
thesis on that village
back in the seventies and so I go with
her a lot
just cuz she knows the village they
she's been going there so long and I can
speak their local language now but I
couldn't when I first went there so it
was helpful
[Music]
[Laughter]